the person doesn't have at least ten
million dollars we generally send them
to another place we are always busy
people are always getting divorced in
Southern California always all of our
clients are high-profile if you went on
the internet they're easy to find
because they've been in articles they in
they know that on television okay my
initials are L aw I'm a lawyer
I was conceived the night that my dad
and mom found out that he had passed the
bar exam we are a family law firm family
law is often a euphemism for divorce law
there are many repeat clients it's very
difficult to subtly tell a person that
the person that they've picked to spend
their life with is going to be a
disaster the gold-digging [ __ ] no good
but but you know we do our best we we
hint okay what-what does house arrest me
I'm always baffled when they come in and
say well what do you mean I mean I I I
went and did a movie like two days after
we got married and I made 20 million
dollars that's not half hers is it I
said yeah that's why your publicist and
your entertainment attorney and your
agent and your manager all called me and
wanted you to get a prenuptial agreement
but you don't want to so now here we are
then we have to come up with a payment
plan for about 42 million dollars if you
are going to enter into the process of
getting divorced stay away from making
it an acrimonious process no matter how
much money you have you don't want to
spend it and paying divorce attorneys
and forensic accountants and retired
judges and experts and all those people
let's take it down to 72 million in 79
and then I say to people all the time
this is gonna be terrible for your face
this v-star making out huh don't make
that face you're never gonna meet
somebody else if you make that face
figure out a way to make something
positive out of it don't make it you
know the end of life make it the end of
a miserable time period and now start
the next chapter of your life and your
family